hi i'm betsy and today i'm going to show
you how to make my neapolitan ice cream
cone cupcakes i love alliteration what
can i say
i did test this recipe once before i
made them i was definitely a little
nervous that the layers weren't going to
work out but they ended up working out
really well what i really love about
this recipe is that it requires mostly
store-bought ingredients
[Music]
so you have vanilla cake batter
strawberry cake batter and brownie
batter so you may be wondering why i
chose to use brownie batter instead of
just a chocolate cake batter like i did
for strawberry and vanilla well the
chocolate is going to be the base of our
layers and brownie batter tends to be
more dense than chocolate cake batter so
it'll provide that stronger base your
layers will be less likely to bleed into
each other so before filming this little
segment i actually read through some
tips that some tasty fans shared on our
website tasty.co we do read them and one
tasty fan had a really really great tip
that i think you'll find super useful so
he suggested to make your distribution
of your batters a little easier use a
piping bag and honestly i can't believe
i didn't think of that but that is a
really great tip this will also ensure
that your layers will be a little bit
more evenly distributed and less likely
to bleed into each other so you can have
those really nice
distinct layers so keep sharing your
tips because they're really good and
they're super helpful for other people
who make these recipes regularly again
it's totally fine if your layers kind of
bleed into each other a little bit i'll
personally love a great marble effect
and your cupcakes are still going to
taste really great
[Music]
so decorating these was probably my
favorite part of this recipe because in
my opinion they look like real
soft-serve ice cream cones so i decided
to use vanilla frosting for this but you
can obviously get creative with your own
favorite flavors like chocolate frosting
strawberry frosting i did use an open
star piping tip to kind of create that
soft serve effect but you can get
creative with your own piping tips that
you have at home you're still gonna have
an awesome ice cream cone at the end of
the day rainbow sprinkles are probably
my favorite thing of all time because it
just makes me really happy but what's
great about this recipe is obviously you
don't have a melty mess like running
down your fingers from ice cream it's a
different way to kind of take advantage
of those ice cream cones so after the
rainbow sprinkles obviously you gotta
put a little cherry on top to kind of
bring it all together i swear these will
probably be a huge hit at like a kid's
birthday party i know my niece and
nephew would probably go crazy over them
you could honestly eat this as if you
were eating a real ice cream cone maybe
you want to save a little bit more of
the frosting and not eat that first but
you know work your way around the cone
and have some fun with it
i guess there's no like really easy way
to eat this
[Music]
you